winter is finally finally dropped this
is a spoiler free episode I think I
think assume you're what episode
wonderful latest season yeah I mean if
you haven't watched it by now all 38
million if you guys have downloaded up
illegally through our channels well you
know what this is working out pretty
well because we're doing the Game of
Thrones design challenge and this is
part 2 we're doing the word mark today
and it's a three part challenge okay so
part two just as a quick refresher we
didn't get as many people submitting
logos Matthew something I'm a little
disappointed a little bit I wonder why I
don't know maybe it's hard to do a word
mark they didn't take the oath I am
Chris doe the protector of the realms
the father of the future breaker of
chains and student debt that's as far as
I got here we go guys so you're supposed
to design a word mark for your chosen
house so if you participate in part one
you continue on using the same house you
can switch of course and if you're just
jumping in then you would go back and
design a sigil and that's okay remember
the different houses that we have to
work with House Stark House Lannister
Targaryen Baratheon Tyrell Greyjoy Tully
Aran and Martell those are the great
houses of Westeros Westeros II oh I
forgot no that's it Martell there we go
and what we wanted to do is to give you
some guidelines as to how to design your
mark make sure that it's memorable that
it's appropriate and that there's some
customization to the letter forms and
this time we were very clear to tell you
guys to make it only black and white no
gradients and I flashed a couple
examples Matthew thinks I might have
steered you some of you wrong looking at
these examples but whatevs we got the
whole crew in here we got the whole cast
and and team from the game of Thrones
series I don't care about control the
sound board it's gonna be wild today
it's gonna be wild
okay there are some logos you know and
then what I was really looking for was
just to encourage you just have a little
bit of fun but we still want to observe
the rules of good design and I was a
little reluctant to even show you these
other ones that have a little bit too
much stuff going on but hey whatever so
we're looking at it let's take a look at
your work this is the moment we're all
been we've all been waiting for now
those are the guys that don't know not
yet don't jump to jump and jonah Jameson
one bit I'll tell you when we're gonna
go do it
he's having a little coffee this morning
so he's ready to go I hope you're ready
to go people are saying I'm a little
cranky maybe but not right now I'm in a
good mood you guys so first up is house
Aaron and the mottos as high as honor
and I think it's a falcon okay so here's
the first entry here and I have some
thoughts on this Matthew I have some
thoughts so let's jump over to my iPad
who is that who is that can you read the
name Matthew I was even looking down
there and you reminded me hey read the
name yeah right now isn't he he's up
front he won the first challenge won the
first child he has the most points he's
on the top of the leaderboard okay so I
like this this is using a what typefaces
do we know it's a good serif typeface
and he's added these little bits these
little bits right let me can i zoom in
it no I cannot ooh I shouldn't have done
that
so he's added little bits in there and I
think that's kind of nice he's he's also
done what what is called his ligatures
where the one letter form the leg of the
are connect with the other serif mm-hmm
and that's sometimes really cool to do
and he's mostly solving spatial issues
like here here looking at that so it
feels pretty balanced to me he's got
these little talons the hooks there let
me undo all this stuff right I think I
might do this it'll get rid of it okay
cool but I think it's maybe just a
little bit too much Matthew yeah I think
there's too many of those little hooks
or claws there at the bottom on the
serifs yeah but I like the idea of just
like a subtle amount so what could we do
to clean it up a little bit I don't
think this thing needs a lot of work
done
to it by my by my eye so what I'm gonna
say is let's try and get rid of these
extra ones here hmm okay
and we want to get rid of those so that
we're left well maybe even this one so
we're left with a hook here at the
bottom of the a and then we're left with
one on the bottom of the end so it'll
terminate like a normal serif and then
we just add a little flourish a lot of
times what you need to do in logo design
is to show restraint now through the
magic of television I'm gonna show you
what it looks like we just placed a
white box over it over here and if you
cut back to my keynote deck it's done
magically magic like that it's just a
subtle little thing that's all we need
you're right one downloading every
single sound I think it's ready to go
he's very exciting today as he should be
I wish we had some snow in inside the
studio but it's a lot warmer in here
than it looks okay how many people are
watching right now 81 a whopping 81
Maeve opportunity in the live Game of
Thrones episode critique review
challenge location just went out so
people are trickling in okay people keep
keep telling somebody go grab a friend
tell them what's up and you might see
your work and you might get a critique
let's see so the next one is just one
right here um let's see who this one's
by oh it's my kin so again man kento is
all over the place yeah my god my gosh
okay I messed up on my deck here so let
me take a look at this first
you know usually what I want to do is
just look at a mark before I go and rip
it apart okay so I think he's using a
similar type face similar serif typeface
but this one's even bolder than the last
one and it's got what I can tell is a
falcon right here cuz I can see the
little head of the Falcon and it's got
these wings at the bottom I think it's a
nice idea Matthew mm-hmm I think it's a
really nice idea but the problem is
right now it looks like three fingers
alright and it looks really weird right
and the a feels a little separated from
the rest of the type hmm like I feel
well maybe
that's part of the idea it feels like
it's lifting off I don't know but it
feels like the a is actually ascending
and it's not sitting on the same
baseline mm-hmm
I think there's something here that can
work and let me see if again I'm just
gonna try to whiteout this part it's
just too much stuff see what we thought
we feel about this is me doing this all
in keynote you guys is not even
Photoshop so bear with me we use tools
in unusual ways that's what we do so is
there enough there for you to read that
it's a falcon I don't think so it's not
enough I think it was too much like he
clipped its claws yeah so maybe I think
it's in the design of the head of the
Falcon up like here I think we just
designed that a little bit different we
can make it work but we also have to
remember I think he had a symbol right
of a bird or something up here for his
residual yeah he did two different ones
for air and I remember so if we have a
bird here let's just say that was a bird
there or whatever mm-hmm do we need
another bird here right I just think
that's maybe a little bit too much right
but the subtleties are nice like his
previous one yeah with the claws I think
those two things would pair well with
each other and I know what a lot of you
guys are thinking because this is a
second
kento yoshida one if you cut to my
laptop I think a lot of the designers
who know they're just like oh my gosh
this
how many entries did he do I don't know
how many he made into the top fifty but
I know that's how some people might be
feeling all right so he's gonna kill us
with the numbers again isn't he kill us
with the ball he went purchase amount
that's right okay let's go back to my
deck here so here's the next entry here
and this one oh look at this one here
hmm
first from far away it looks like it's
torn paper and it makes this really hard
to read but what I think here is he's
who is this this is William Youngblood
what up Youngblood I think the the issue
here is he's put the veil in there and
the moon there's a lot of people are
just adding too much stuff into their
ward mark knowing very well that it's
gonna live with the sigil you know yeah
yeah I agree I think it's a little too
complicated I like how he explored this
though this feels like it would be great
if it was a movie poster mmm right it
could be cool for it kind of ruins me
like predator or something like that
that's it's pretty rad mm-hmm but you're
right it doesn't feel appropriate for
the the use case here yeah so I'm gonna
make a suggestion for you William
Youngblood I'm I think you should finish
out let's say this is the baseline right
let's finish out the letter form here
and don't don't get too tricky here's
the rule with this kind of stuff you
know just have one trick this is where
you being a one-trick pony is actually
good and then you could either use the
veil there or the crescent moon which I
like so if I were to to draw this here
it could be a solid a like this and just
have one crescent moon that looks
terrible now that I'm seeing it
no wonder you do that way what do I know
about local design okay no you be
careful so I just think maybe then this
could work I think I drew the base line
a little bit too low but I also think it
it being in the area it's like really
high up so maybe having a taller letter
form a more condensed letter form might
get that feeling that it's up high mm-hm
being squat and low and maybe that's one
of the problems I'm having with this
mark right
it feels a little squashed mm-hmm okay
all right let's move on let's go on to
the next one which is the last entry
here for Aaron whoo a lot of stuff going
on you're Matthew whoa okay Wow
how do we feel about this I think the
interior details inside the letter forms
like if we squint and and shrink that I
feel like that's probably too much
details in there I kind of like the idea
between the the hooks on the a and on
the end that's kind of a fun thing it
feels like the talons on the claws that
we saw in kento's who's is this can you
see that yeah this will young you know
young blood yeah I think there's some
interesting stuff going on the the
letter spacing the kerning between the a
are in the are R and the ry like they're
all a little off where the a in the end
feel like they're too far apart and then
the r ry feels like it's okay so let me
see if I can illustrate this for
everybody you need to bring these in yep
right mm-hmm so you you guys recall what
you want to do is look at your trickiest
turning pair the hardest one to bring
together which is usually when you have
a straight line and something like the Y
shape mm-hmm so I'm just gonna block
this out let's just pretend that's the
letter N because this creates a lot of
volume here and there's you can only
push those together so tight before the
integrity of the letter forms get ruined
or they have to touch the ligatures are
gonna happen now you can do that by
customizing the letter form a little bit
so how do you do that so let me see if I
can take this moment to do a little
quick dirty demo
it's dirty demo day so what wouldn't do
is this I'm gonna draw the line right so
if we have the R and say the R is here
ten more just to fill that in real quick
what the heck is little path you are you
playing two sound effects at the same
time yeah okay okay yeah so if I have
the letter in here just do this real
quick and then he has this kind of
mm-hmm
exaggerated thing I listen this is kind
of little tricky to do right so now we
got to get this Y in here so the way
that you can do the Y's you can raise
the Y up so that you can bring the
letter together so create some space in
there yeah
salud okay thank you Chris talk a little
bit about your analogy you're like
you're pouring Stan between the
characters yeah
so you have to look at it in a volume
sense not and we're trying to do optical
letter spacing right so it's not going
to be about mathematically that a lot of
people make this mistake so they'll say
well this measurement and this
measurement feel about the same right
and but what you have to do really do is
you have to look at the space in between
so that's like you pouring sand and the
volume that exists between those things
and so the tightest kerning pair is
always going to be two circles like that
so you have two letter OS they're gonna
be really tight together cuz there's a
lot of space in between and usually your
regular one is going to be two letter
eyes or a letter n in an eye right so
like let's say that's n so this is gonna
be your default so this is really tight
this is normal and when you have
diagonals like two letter s next to each
other there's a lot of volume here so
that is gonna be tricky to that's what
you're looking at so there's only so
many shapes that you can have to deal
with a circle and a line a circle and an
angle that kind of stuff so when you go
in and work on this stuff or what I
would suggest is modifying the letter
forms so that your kerning looks good
hmm and that's really where the little
flourishes should be driven from
it's not necessarily to illustrate
remember what segi aviv said which is
logos or punctuation they're not
communication agreed thank you thank you
sir so if I were to finish out this logo
I'm not going to drop these ARS down too
far because everything is yelling at me
look at me look at me it's like that
little bratty kid I don't want to do
that okay now I can tell my letter
spacings jank right now when I put in
the a I was thinking you you have a
shape going down and a shape going up
what if you did that letter a like this
somehow to make it work that way
and I don't know how to design that just
yet but I'm just gonna play around here
a little bit okay so that these two
shapes are symmetrical mmm the I likes
symmetry okay so I don't know I don't
know how to make that work yet because
that's not very legible either but I
kind of like that it feels like from the
top view it could be the spread of the
bird's wing or something
mm-hmm I know this looks terrible guys
forgive me forgive me Father right
that's that's what I would do
okay that's it I like the little details
these little barbed things the inline
detail and those are nice maybe there's
too many of them and the way that are
integrated together but I like having a
little bit that detail okay good job
William Youngblood come on boy all right
let's move on to house Baratheon ours is
the fury House Baratheon Baratheon
symbol is the stag which is a boy deer
with the horns so first up we have who
do we have this is taejun Kim I remember
at agent agent over round one oh wow
good memory Matthew I remember nobody my
memories not so good like that Wow okay
there's a lot going on here it
definitely has a vibe and a feel it
feels kind of very gothic Transylvania
like vampire ish and then I think we
were looking at your logos yesterday and
somebody's like I feel like that's a lot
like Castlevania
the video game logo right okay that's
what's going on we got a lot of tricks
going on we have a giant drop cap okay
so what I mean by drop cap these were
used a lot in illuminated manuscripts
back in the day like if you pull out the
Old Testament or these fancy books
they're gonna happen everyone use this
big drop cap the thing with the drop cap
is you can't just take a letter and
scale it up because what happens you're
on let me do this in red is this stroke
becomes really big compared to that one
right so what you have to do is you have
to draw it over you have to redraw it
right so the the widths match okay so
that's that's kind of like my big thing
here is like there's a lot of like weird
stuff going on here it does feel very
retro ish in that kind of old-school
Transylvania Castlevania game vibe
mm-hmm okay
so I think what we need to do is
everybody like you want to find your one
trick your one thing and just build your
entire mark around that and try to solve
problems like this try to solve these
kinds of problems don't invent those so
that's when you go into modify the
letter forms okay
and I'm also noticing here or maybe it's
an illusion just don't don't forget this
guys when you have a flat serif it sits
on the base line but if you have a
curved or an angular thing it should
overshoot it ever so slightly so that it
feels optically I'm exaggerating here
that they sit on the same base line why
because I said optically no supper for
you go to your room all right that's
what you want to do okay so it's called
an overshoot over shoot and if there's a
circle it does the same thing it's gonna
go a little bit under the baseline okay
and you do it for optical reasons
because when you when you zoom out
you'll start to feel like it doesn't
quite hit the baseline
okay let's move on that's taejun Kim
next up who do we have we all we have
another one from taejun Kim OH the way
there's so many some people are really
good and they they put a lot in there I
put a lot of effort they divisible one
so I applaud that that's awesome yeah I
love that I love that too so let's look
at this one we probably should say this
if you haven't watched Game of Thrones
and you plan to I guess these memes are
gonna ruin it for you well it's mine
okay so this one is another one for a
house Baratheon there's a couple of
issues with this so let's get into it
first of all word marks like this have a
problem because there's so much space so
in order for this to fit on a small ring
or something very tiny looks us imagine
a business card you'd have the skills
sing down so small it would become
almost illegible even at this scale you
see all this detail in here has been
added these lines they could you could
barely see them now imagine if you had
to make them smaller you wouldn't be
able to see them at all I got another
problem with this one is that this be
usually a two story letter like this the
top bowl is going to be set in a little
bit because otherwise what happens it's
doing what it feels like it's leaning
over right it's crowding it a little
crying over it almost feels like they
flip this upside down mmm where the B
the the the bowl of the B should be
bigger on the bottom and they flipped it
over so that's one problem there the
other one the other big problem that
it's pretty obvious to me is the house
house it doesn't quite look like an H I
don't even know if we need it I mean I
would rather just see Baratheon right oh
okay right right good point
okay well Matthew just ended the
conversation right right so what III see
why because Baratheon is very long right
and I think this is actually a pretty
nice typeface right like it has some
cool detail it has this these little
barbs sticking out I don't know what
that's called it has these triangular
sail
so some pretty cool old-school detail
here it's a good typeface that you're
building this on and I think trying to
mix two typefaces becomes really tricky
because this feels like from another
universe and I think they did house
baratheon because they wanted it to take
up more space so if you were to do this
what I would do is this baratheon
hopefully I can spell then I would do
house up on top hmm so that it feels
more like a lock-up a unit okay and then
try to design it to fill in the space so
this is where you can have a little bit
of fun you could try to do a bigger B
here now that looks terrible maybe it's
put on one of those curved paths so that
you can make it tight like Everlast
there for last logo right okay I think
that's enough for this one let's move on
what do we have up next is Pedro bricio
la Pedro mm-hmm a lot to look at here
there is a lot to look at okay let me
process this okay I like the antlers you
do it's it's fun I I think it's a nice
nice little flourish a nice little
element there I don't think that the
execution is is solid in terms of how
its incorporated mm-hmm like if we look
at the curves of the AR and the curves
of the oh it feels like it's just kind
of latched on and dropped on there on
the top rather than it being connected
to the round curve of the AR and the
round curve of the oh okay so I think
there are little things to do to help
incorporate those elements a little bit
better alright so let me get in here I
I'm gonna try some surgery here guys
let's see if it works I'm gonna try to
draw this part in here I'm gonna try to
make it be complete as part of the top
of the are right and I'm just I'm gonna
spat spackle over this part right here
so that that critical juncture is going
to connect now I'm gonna switch over to
my white let's see if I can get this to
work where I can finish part out a
little bit and get it to connect there
and then I would like to break this here
and then we get rid of this bottom part
that I don't think we need us Baratheon
okay guys keynote that's what I'm doing
right okay so I like this typeface it's
got a triangular serif sun bracketed
serif so I guess or maybe that's
bracketing but it's not curved some
other problems I have is this the ours
is the fury now I don't mind that you
add in the model I think it's kind of
nice but really fill in the space guys
really work it in here so it's all
customized into here maybe this is where
it needs to go ours is the theory and
these little triangular doodads these
what do they call these get dingbats you
think that's the term they're called
dingbats I feel like they're out of
character mm-hmm and I think this mark
could look really good on a bot of
scotch like one of those really premium
prime reserve age 30 years and a oak
barrel smoked and not I feel like it
could get there so let's keep working on
this I like this so I'm directly so
pedra good job you know and I think the
secondary typeface doesn't quite
complement the other one as nicely so
let's look into that as well
all right I'm just more and more
impressive Apple every day it's keen oh
I wish I could do this on my regular
keynote so here's the last entry to
baratheon this one's kind of nice ooh
okay
I think pagan look yeah so this is from
Lillian Figueroa
nobody's gonna join me on that one okay
I've just left alone an island to die by
myself okay
winter has thank you thank you thank you
okay this one I think is based on these
older I want to say like Gaelic or Irish
yeah celtic celtic typefaces right it
feels like it and so how's a good
throwback quality to it
theone maybe the h isn't super legible
but for the most part I like it's really
simple maybe what we can do is tighten
up the letter spacing a little bit and I
like this part let me get in here this O
has three lines through it and correct
my memory if I'm wrong all you Game of
Thrones fans out there I think there are
three brothers right
there's Stannis right there's Renly and
there's Robert wrecking robear so that's
kind of a nice like three brothers who
are going to inherit the throne and
there's some conflict there I won't tell
you what happens so I kind of like that
it's a little simple thing for the house
and the family the only problem is over
time when their children theoretically
take over the throne there may be a
problem okay I'm not gonna say anything
I know you guys are giggling okay all
right let's move on next up is house
Bolton our blades are sharp
non-affiliated not affiliated with
Michael Bolton what's your son what's
this one song don't remember coming out
right now
karaoke winters come we're doing it my
lady
house Bolton are they the flayed white
man yeah the flayed man the flayed man
thank you for reminding me of that so
here we go here's one logo that made the
cut it it's reminiscent of the other one
that's got a got the Celtic vibe to it
I see oh very clever so there's the
flayed man right there which they hang
people they don't hang them the
to a cross that's right but I think
they've doomed this way right there hang
on what's a down today Oh actually I
forget now on the internet figure that
for me please who is it is it like that
so this feels oddly really friendly
until you realize what that's what they
do
what they're known for which is the skin
people I have a nail them to these X's
so I think in terms of appropriateness
this is where it's thrown me off
we have some other funky things going on
here so let's look at house Bolton okay
so this is a good use of modifying
letter forms you'll notice that Kendra
brought up the T so that the L because
this is a very tricky lettering
combination at kerning pair here so if I
were to draw the L right the way that
it's drawn here we have this long leg of
the L and then we have the T let me do
this kind of quickly here it's kind of
flared ends and it looks like that right
so what happens is you have all the
space to deal with and now that means
you have to push all the letter forms
apart so then o would have to look live
out here somewhere right so this is a
good use of modifying the letter so
Kendra bump this base up so that I'm
assuming she can move the letter forms
closer together and I like that we have
some little funky things going on here
right a little bit funky and the reason
why is your eye wants to continue this
across and it doesn't quite come across
right there's some funny things going on
there there's definitely some
opportunities for things to flow
together a lot better mm-hmm
so there's there's there's a lot of
potential there mmm and remember when
you're drawing letter forms like this I
don't know if you scan this in if this
is really a typeface or whatever but
keep in mind that a typeface is supposed
to be a family and there are things that
bring it together so when you look at
the way that these serifs are drawn some
are sharp and don't taper like the B
right and then you'll notice here the N
cooks in a funny way and then the
bottoms of the N are different and
unique and aren't shared anywhere so it
could start to feel like we've cobbled a
lot of things together mm-hmm and that's
the danger there okay that's all just
something to think about okay let's move
on to house Greyjoy house Greyjoy
they're the great Pirates of the sea and
what's the island called that iron
something iron island
thank you Venice is an alley-oop Matthew
took me halfway and I'm gonna put it in
the basket here house Greyjoy their
motto is we do not so they just rape and
plunder because they have no fertile
lands to grow crops on kind of like the
old days of the Vikings I think it kind
of feels like that like the Nordic yeah
the Nordic things and they're their
masters of the sea okay so let's get
into a Greyjoy and their sigil is I'm a
Kraken right yes a giant Kraken okay
bring on the Kraken okay so we have
tentacles from a Kraken in here I like
the attract out type I really like that
serif typeface yeah it's really nice I
think the issues I have with it is the
weight of the tentacles coming off of
the art mm-hmm feel like they're
unbalanced like they're very heavy
relative to the weight of the details
and the in the in the type mm-hmm
there's some nice things going on here
do you think we need two tentacles I
feel like one would the bottom one is
really nice actually yeah so I'm gonna
go and do a little digital surgery and
see if I can't cut that off a little bit
dang so good I pad I'm rocking the iPad
pro to you guys I'm just saying that
because I'm flexing you know some
precision there it can be oh no oh no
guys oh my goodness
mark have we lost all the viewers we had
earlier
I think we are going backwards in time
and we're losing viewers
okay so I don't know how you guys feel
that's one trick yeah yeah let me show
them the before and after
okay the before and after you can have
it back and forth yeah it's more
balanced I don't know if I like the
tentacle crossing over on the Y like
that yes the J fields are right yep but
the Y it feels like it's disrupting the
legibility of the Y so if that actually
came under and then loop back up and
maybe crossed over the J I think that
wouldn't be a little bit more like
Mathews talking about that part we have
to be mindful of the intersections
mm-hmm the intersections all right so
maybe it's dropped down a little bit
right Matthew what you want it to go all
the way under I think it might be nice
if it goes all the way under the Y all
right so I'm gonna pretend to draw that
stroke and let's see what happens here
hmm just a guess right so something like
that so you've preserved integrity of
the letter form I can try to test my
ability to draw using this using keynote
look at keynote there Apple call me
maybe I know I just met you sounds a
little crazy there we go I don't know if
you guys can hear that on the internet
okay
someone switch over to this black thing
what was that
did you hear that Matthew yeah hold on
just knowing it's difficult to explain
something popped in this room you
thought yes I am I need take two it's
kind of like um okay I think that's what
Matthew sorry but it feels a little limp
now great like there's not enough snap
to it so when you draw a letter forms
like this we're always looking at the S
curve when it it's too flat like this it
doesn't feel right so what you want to
do is probably have a come down and come
back up so it's got a nice motion
dynamic whipped to it little whip can
you Nene okay it's speaking of whip look
at this one
oh and
oh my god this this is from Sylvain
rotate row ta something like that
there's an extra syllable there or vowel
I'm sorry
Greyjoy wow this looks like one of those
films where the girl comes up from the
drain with our hair oh yeah
the hunting or the whatever what it's
called the ring the ring the ring yeah
there's a lot of stuff going on here
the problem here is I get the idea that
it's the Kraken but it feels like it's
too wispy and doesn't have enough weight
at the end so if we were to just go back
in and add those weird little hands at
the back end of this it could feel a
little bit more like the Kraken
I don't know why I say that in a picture
I'm in Austria everything now what do
you guys think does it read a little bit
better I feel like it's the things are a
little plugged up after the G like the G
oh that's the major party yeah I feel
and then the weights after like the the
E and the J feel a little inconsistent
yeah in Greyjoy's yeah it's like there's
little things I like the the weight of
the G but I think if everything else
were to help balance that out and then
it would feel a little bit more legible
because if we made that really small
it's gonna be very very hard to read
there's all kinds of legibility issues
it's kind of gumming up all over here
there's the parts we're talking about
right mm-hm and there's some
inconsistencies inconsistencies in the
weight the the crossbar of the J of
greyjoy it needs to be a little bit more
weight here it almost feels like this
that somebody's took the Trader Joe's
logo and put a crack on all over it
instead of modifying the letter forms if
you're not an expert letter form
designer drawing one from scratch
sometimes can be very difficult to do
right if I can't zoom in I can't pinch
zoom this my one regret Apple please
allow us to pinch zoom in on this turn
this in to procreate then then I would
be very happy with you but if you focus
in on the e this is what happens here I
want you guys to think about this you
have to follow through on the letter
forms okay let me show you what I mean
let's say it's like that
okay and then you have the crossbar and
the e now if you were to zoom in here
which you can't yours looks a little
different it looks like you drew the
outside and then on the inside you do it
like this so that these two things I'm
gonna grossly exaggerating here these
two things don't line up I always wanted
to do the right thing well you should do
it then okay
okay don't come back for you I think
just do it have your men raise the white
flag and open the gate for going home
not yet we're still in Greyjoy hold on
Theon okay next up next up who do we
have this is Israel Ramirez I like a
chunky this one is mm-hmm
yeah I really like the weight of this
stuff yeah and I like actually the
little flourish on the G so it feels
like a little tentacle curling there and
I like the subtlety of that so I think
this is very smart mmm I want you
everybody to look at this mark I know we
don't like to say these things but I
want you to express to me the feeling
that you get from looking at this now
what it reminds you of just the feeling
okay everybody locking in what do you
think of okay I'm gonna draw something
on here and when you guys agree with me
let me know what does it feel like
to me now
people are just starting to comment what
are they saying with money let's see
nothing yet people are gonna be very
upset I mean a little bit so get that
sound leg ready
someone says watery groovy feeling what
does it feel like I didn't know if
feeling could be watery last time
somebody asked me how you feeling I feel
watery what are you trying to say
tortilla chips yes I am doesn't it feel
like no loud it does not start I know I
don't think so no no I don't think so
status Kris I think you're just bringing
that back agent remember what our buddy
said I can't say it reminds me of yeah
that's right yeah I'm not I didn't say
it reminds me of I use the word it feels
like totally different concept feels
like I'm lost in creepy woods yeah a
little bit okay I'm gonna undo all this
stuff I think conceptually there's some
good stuff there okay let's talk about I
like again the the G and then the J also
they all feel like tentacles to me when
I look at that thing they all feel like
tentacles so those subtle details make
it feel like it's a nice little like
chunky tentacle that's coming down in
there mm-hmm
yeah I mean I think there's a lot of
little details in the typeface of course
we can't zoom in on this where it
doesn't feel like it's like all the
details are dialed in because it looks a
little like around the e yeah oh thanks
for punching in yeah things look like
around the Oh like that chunkiness i i
appreciate that from afar but when we
get close in on the details i feel like
those things could be a little bit more
refined oh that's kind of cool it's a
little fun right now yeah it might be
too much but it is generally I like the
idea behind that where if you add little
things like that might be a nice little
nod and so on okay don't hate me because
I'm beautiful don't do it that's it
let's move on look at this one oh my
gosh this is from Enrique Alonso who
also changed at I taste at the bottom
shame shame there's a lot going on this
one gray
range away no what is that this is one
where okay okay okay
Neffe you should have brought your
outfit you should brought your done
outfit in here it will look really good
I have one we need a bigger we need a
bigger budget here we're running on like
on nickels and dimes send us money yes
guys come on we'll make this a more
exciting show we can do better
there's so much going on in this thing I
said I don't even know where to begin
there's little lines and then there's
little things at the end of those lines
so many flourishes going on we got a big
G and a backwards J whoa if you didn't
know what this said how would you read
this boy yeah it's a it's a little some
letters are clear right so this is one
of those things where I think you you
have like good calligraphy skills and
these letter forms are drawn really well
Enrique but I think it's just too
bananas too much stuff going on okay use
a little more restraint and then you put
your creativity into that part okay we
got a lot of great joy so we have one
more here cat
Salvador Rodriguez did I say that right
Jonah yes we did okay rodriguez
rodriguez Salvador Rodriguez okay hmm I
like this one what are we thinking here
Matthew I like the the weathered look on
this thing because it feels like
weathered wood
yeah on a ship so that G and the the
details on the oh those little notches
kind of feels like old wood so that's
pretty nice and then also on the bottom
the flourishes again they've maybe the
ideas that they feel like tentacles
mm-hmm maybe it's a little much on the Y
and the Y I feel I wish those two things
weren't repeated that same way I wish
the the details on the far Y was a
little bit more exaggerated and maybe
the one on the middle is a lot less okay
I could do that let me we'll start
working on that with
magic pen so maybe we just started
limiting things so you noticed that
every time we have some problems we just
go in we just start deleting until we
feel like oh maybe you could end there
maybe maybe that's okay
right and then Matthew you were talking
about the second why right you want it
to be more prominent so I'm just gonna
erase all this stuff right now mm-hmm
is the Internet mad at me because I'm
using keynote I mean they were mad at me
when I using Photoshop now they're
probably going bananas I think they're
more intrigued come on chance some
people are wondering if it's only on the
back so it sounds like they want to try
it no I believe you can get keynote for
the PC yeah but I'm using with an iPad
pro and you need to be able to do that
so that you can draw on the surface okay
all right so I'm gonna try to draw this
part back out right Matthew and what did
do before it drop back down or do you
forget oh there's the before it curled
it it curled back into itself okay so
let me just try this and see how bad I
can make it look mmm and then you guys
tell me if it's okay so what I'm trying
to do here is I'm trying to mirror
letterforms and complete the shape here
yeah I like this what I'm trying to do
right so usually when you do those
ligatures that's what you're supposed to
use them for which is to close up space
and make a nice tight configuration okay
so I noticed that if that's a little
whippy right there maybe I need to do a
little bit something similar there and
now I think we need to fix the jury how
do you guys say gee in Spanish hey in
French it's Shay yeah okay
are you just kidding okay so here's some
problems I have with the G I don't know
if we want to close off the G because I
think that hurts the legibility of the G
by having a clear crossbar there I think
it makes it a little easier to read now
we have a new problem I'm gonna draw a
blue line here to show you what the
problem is if we draw a bass line if I
can draw a straight line
I think what we need to do is lower this
part a little bit so that it feels like
it's on that same line mmm because it's
really thick here and it feels like it's
rising also because of this like where's
the bottom of the G okay so I'm gonna
undo that and then I'm gonna draw on top
of this okay are there any comments that
need to be aware of on social no people
are just not saying that they like this
one they said it feels pirate ish yeah
that's the term and question for me is
that G is supposed to represent some
type of creature yeah well I I think
they're having fun with it getting that
vibe of swashbuckling pirates at the sea
at sea so I don't know if it's going to
also double as like a tentacle tentacle
right now when once I erase it can you
guys see now that it feels like the G is
a little higher than everything else
yeah or is it just me yeah no it feels
like it's lifting up a little a little
bit right yeah so what I want to do now
is I want to delete this part and want
to redraw this so that it dips a little
bit lower so it's optically gonna be
okay and we can do that with the first
letter usually you can do it with the
first letter who needs Photoshop and
illustrator when you got keynote don't
you well I didn't ask you could you hit
her okay so that's one way to do it I
feel like we want to complete the shape
here mm-hmm and I don't have those
skills I mean it could curl back around
right like if it extended off the bottom
of the G gets a little thin and then
comes back around and thickens out yeah
we can do that I think or would that
wait it funny well we can always try
Matthew this doesn't cost anything to
try so I'm gonna delete some of this
right so every time I delete it I like
it even better but we have a problem
there okay now once I hook this back
like your Matthew st. here and you come
back this way it stops reading like a G
oh sorry I meant it goes down and then
curls back okay yeah we gotta go the
other way so oh shoot okay
like that yeah but like a bit better
bigger could be too much you know the
problem is the letter Q is like that
with the letter G is like that and the
lowercase G depending on if you have a
two-story G would look like that so we
have to kind of do something that people
are going to recognize as the letter G
so I think that's danger right there
okay yeah I think it's problem saying
that was a bad bad idea no no no we
gotta try things so I think I know how
to solve it Matthew
hmm we have to use another letter we
can't use this one it's starting to feel
like a wood cut letter because of all
these like little little traces of the
old letter form so now I'm thinking we
need to bring this Y over and it could
work maybe clever man right so it could
work that way what do you guys think
what is the our YouTube audience think
they hate it when I call them the
Internet's I don't know they're like
it's disrespectful to me
the G looks like a hook I think they're
talking about one of the earlier
versions yeah people are saying did you
close the crossbar on the E and other
people are wondering if we should really
have the dots on top of the J looking
like that
I like the dot I don't mind the dot
mm-hmm I don't have a problem with that
at all no yeah one thing I'm ok with
that and there's an opportunity here
potentially to do something with the top
of the crossbar here I'm not gonna do it
I'm just gonna show you it needs to be a
higher crossing there so they can make
it nice and tight okay I think I'm gonna
leave this alone at this point let's
move on to the next thing
moving on moving on to house
Lannister their motto is hear me roar
House Lannister
I am Tyrion Lannister of Casterly Rock
thank you very much Tyrion and let's
take a look at the first entry to house
lannister this is from cm Kevin cm Kevin
hi Kevin from the UK this is not your
cousin yet is it no no no okay he's
still looking there how many viewers are
we up to now mark we are at 187 wow
that's pretty good that's that's pretty
good
we picked up 100 that deserves a bell
ring thank you very much everybody I
appreciate you I appreciate you turning
it into our show
okay let's look at this here mm a lot of
things to look at here I think there's
some elements of leaves or perhaps the
bushy tail of a lion
maybe yeah it kind of feels like that at
the end of the are mm-hmm but then it on
the left side it feels like a leaf right
like we're not sure what the heck it is
mm-hmm so what Matthew's talk about so
over here this feels like a lion's tail
this feels like a leaf so it's a house
of leaf and lions right lounging lazily
right Lannister I like what this person
is doing with the seraphs mm-hmm the
stairs like there's some nice details in
here I think like that s is awesome the
way that this finishes here yeah like
that's very unusual but that that's very
nice I think just overall if I'm looking
at that and squinting at that it just
feels like there's too much detail in
there so it's very difficult to read mmm
specifically the L mm-hmm because it's a
tea from far away or or an eye mm-hmm
right because that bottom of the L
doesn't feel like it's oh yeah it's
heavy and now for season I think that's
very legible from far away so here's my
biggest issue is if we do know any
better we read this as a Lannister or
canister that's cruel one rules the
Seven Kingdoms and one prepares the
leather for the armor that everybody
wears the tanah stirs I see it more than
I ins a mr. C and mr. yeah so there's a
simple thing that
can do all we need to do is move the
vertical part so that it's not
symmetrical and it's like right in the
middle that's the problem okay now here
we go surgery time so I'm gonna put your
knife it's more like a scalpel
I think Gorton talked about this so I'm
going to delete that part I'm gonna get
in here and maybe delete the leaf the
eraser that's already feeling more like
an L yeah right just because we're going
to make sure that the L is illegible now
remember before when I said if you scale
up a letter form that you need to make
sure the thickness is consistent with
the other letter form so I'm looking at
the stroke of the T and the end the
letter and I'm sorry and I think I need
to thin this out just a little bit so it
feels consistent it's not a little
closer closer okay Kevin saying those
flourishes are meant to be the lion's
tail yeah the critique is on point yeah
I'm pretty sure it's supposed to be the
lion's tail so I need to be able to do
something here so this reads like an L
and I'm gonna bring this down and
probably do something like yes maybe
yeah that looks better and I don't know
how to draw a lion's tail so I'm gonna
approximate it so it would seem hmm we
have some other problems but I've
created some dead space in between but I
want to make sure it reads okay so we
have I'm gonna point out some of the
problem areas we have some arrows here
and here mm-hmm this is awkward isn't it
okay Laurie how do we do this then
Matthew I don't think Matthew has ever
had so much fun than today with this I'm
gonna give me a sound board I know he's
gonna go crazy I go crazy it's gonna
banana the Internet can tell me if I'm
being annoying I could kill it no just
keep doing it
we don't live for the internet what do
you guys think of the sound effects I so
I think the the end the first end
possibly could dip down a little bit
lower to help close that space
mm-hmm I think that could be one way
that we could plug up that hole mmm
Logan howls what you're gonna do so when
I'm flipping an unexpected pleasure
sorry okay you gonna comment the
soundboard is overkill haha there you go
Matthew we only have one complaint I
think what I need to do is be mindful
that I need to close up this space oh
that's that's why I feel much better
right shaggy tail there were something
like that that's pretty nice it's nice
that it counterbalances with the top of
the are the flourish that's coming off
at the top of the arc
mm-hmm kind of feels like now they're
they're balancing out and they're
meeting together at the at the I like
they're directing your your eye to the
eye the sensor here aye aye captain
all right so we can also do something
with this we're gonna hook it so that
there's a little detail there and we can
finish off the rest of this you can also
just drop this down if you wanted to you
know the those baselines don't have to
line up so I'm gonna erase a little bit
of this the barbs you also have a
comment about the a someone's saying if
you remove the flourish on the left of
the a yeah close up the gap with the L
yeah we're gonna need to bring it closer
together what they're talking about is
this we need to bring these letter forms
closer together and we can modify this
to be a little shorter and it's hoop
right and then we will be done okay very
good
sham Kevin let's move on move it on the
next one
whoo now yeah Nath yeah yeah Wow okay I
like this mark a lot Matthew mm-hmm
feels very regal it feels like the
Lannisters this is like if you guys want
to stay in the premium Hotel in Milan
stay at the Lannister hotel it feels
like it right here there's a lot going
on in this one and it's got some spacing
issues right so when we talk about
difficult turning pairs the
most difficult one is right here right
the L nay so we have an open-faced
letter form like the L which is almost
always like super tricky to deal with
then you have an a which has that angle
so you're really trying to balance
something that typically looks like this
and this now we do live in Los Angeles
and the way that the LA Dodgers their
logo looks something like this right
Matthew mm-hmm oh yeah solve it yeah
because they're very difficult to bring
together so it's something like that all
you sports people right so that's the
problem we got up resolve that but we
have other problems here look how much
spacing is in here it almost feels like
Alanis er like you you have to go to the
emergency room at the Landis hotel this
is where you go so there's lots of
things that are working really well with
this some of the detail is a little
overwhelming but I just like the feeling
it feels regal it feels like you do rule
the Seven Kingdoms and you think very
highly of yourself don't you Jeffrey
right so what we had to do is we got to
bring those together and we got to work
on this
maybe there's removal of some of the
little details if you can but I like the
feeling of it quite a bit good typeface
choice interesting ideas the flipping of
the letter ends together doesn't it feel
like a fashion house and they'll be out
like a cologne also look along I can see
that it's got a good feeling to it
Lannister by Calvin Klein
all right by Donna Karen okay
house Martell unbowed unbent and broken
house Martell the symbol is like a
flower is that no it's the Sun with this
some of the spear yeah this is me not
even looking at the deck itself good job
Chris right so here's our first and only
entry for house Martell that made the
cut Sandro Vogue Elle Mojo Vogue Elle
there's a lot and Rome interesting
things going on here let's see how they
resolve the L here very different than
the LA that we were just looking at but
there's something interesting about
the details are they're all blending
into each other like the M is kind of
curving into the a which is bleeding
into the R which is bleeding into the L
and then carried on to the little tiny L
so there's a nice flow to this thing yes
yes I like the chunky serif in this
typeface it feels like new century
school book bold or black mm-hmm and the
e and using this kind of e it's kind of
it's a curvy element to it so it's nice
now when I look at this almost it almost
works for me where it dies for me and
it's about to die right now get the ax
out we got some problems here winces ooh
up with this weird tear dropped on the M
boy doesn't that feel funky let me just
don't eliminate it because I can boom
and then I'm not sure I like this loopy
loopy thing at the bottom here too just
I'm not feeling it cut it off here eat
that mmm okay now I'm gonna go back and
I'm gonna fix the serif
hands are steady steady do this and do
that does I feel a little bit more
classic it's cleaner can we see that
before and after
yes before oh yeah so you don't know
what you have until you see what was
before right yeah so like that a lot of
other things
I also don't love this tapered crossbar
of the a because we don't we're not
really seeing that we're seeing things
that are very flat so I'm gonna try and
flatten that out so again with the hands
of a surgeon how are you doing this
well you'll see
oh yeah check that out so we have some
trapped space here and I want to see if
I can free up that space because I
liberate people and their ideas from
delete that what we think about that
Martel Martel pray tell or tell okay
let's do the BMA
before and after well you guys think
everybody that's watching this let me
know if you thought the original
original a or the new Martell brought to
you by house whatever Martell that
didn't even work guys it did not work so
this is the Sun icon with a spear right
yes I can see a beautiful schedule up
here for it yeah really beautiful like a
very Spanish feeling thing mm-hmm
right up here whatever we wind up doing
I think people were doing always you
know I'm talking about Matthew even if
it's super simple like that it that
might look beautiful together house
martell most people are saying be a few
A's but okay Kirk dominantly be all
those that it's a day you could now
leave the room I'm just going to pray I
just kidding
alright love you guys love you guys just
messing around with you alright why so
serious Friday come on Batman okay house
dark House Stark cousin - Jonathan Stark
who's been on the show twice also
brother - Tony from Iron Man coming out
avengers endgame winter is coming that's
their house motto and the direwolf is
there a spirit animal or something like
that so the wolf winter's coming that
are the Watchers of the north what did
he call them I'm gonna make you the of
the North King in the north no not king
of the north mmm like when they were
promising people that you'll be the of
the north know the warden warden of the
warden of the north
that's right alright the Starks the
heroes here we go Stark
OOP there we go
all right it's dark it's kind of shaggy
like a direwolf yeah mm-hmm all right so
it's got a little bit of personality hmm
what do you what do you think about that
Chris when it looks like the direwolf
and it feels a little shaggy you know I
don't mind it if this was a story about
a pack of wolves like Alpha Omega then I
think it would be just fine but winter
is coming yes it is and we need to stay
warm
so people are seeing spidery doesn't
matter ring kind of like the spider legs
they're very hairy oh yeah shoot oh
let's give me the heebie-jeebies right
now okay let's talk about it on a formal
level now let's get let's get rid of our
feelings about this right and let's look
at the T and the ass mmm yeah those are
those are too crowded it's so tart luck
tonight sir but yeah I do like the
typeface a lot yeah the typeface
selected the base type face looks very
appropriate for Stark for whatever
reason is it Trajan one of the oldest
serif typefaces Roman type is it
Trajan it could be it feels like it let
me just point out something real quick
you guys noticed the a how it overshoots
the cap height line the cap line is he
not very subtle it's well it's supposed
to right because what we're saying is
there were a straight line the a needs
to peak a little bit above otherwise it
will not feel even and if you dropped it
geometrically mathematically to that
line it would not look right so I mean
besides the addition of the hairy parts
and that sounded a little funny but the
S and a T that's really where we need
some work right need a little work here
and maybe this is one where it could use
a flourish I don't know maybe it could
use a little flourish for the a like
where you bring that out a little bit
just to eat up some of the space that's
all I got
I don't know what to do with this Mathew
anything no I think if we were just to
open that up somehow
I don't know if you could do it within
the I gave the left side of the T maybe
was a little bit
shorter that might help I don't know
it's it's tough no this is such a crazy
pairing right there yeah I think you
just need a little bit more space and
push this over me the left you could
shorten it like matthew was saying you
see what happens then I can fix it I
believe it did something like this I
can't remember you're allowed to modify
the letter forms to do whatever it is
that you want just to get them to work
okay let's move on the next one is from
Joshua Cleopas Joshua Cleopas winter is
coming okay well I think I see a theme
here between the previous logo and this
one where they want to do a big drop cap
the first initial letter and then it's
just it's fighting all of this but this
one is working a little bit better
in terms of the letter spacing it feels
a little bit more even to me Matthew
mm-hmm and then it's got these little
triangular lines what do you think that
is inside the a it's hard to tell at
this scale hmm I don't know what it is
yeah cuz like the a is broken for a
reason right mm-hmm
it's kind of nice I'm trying to figure
out what it what it means they're like
why that person did it yeah could be you
know what I just realized Matthew what I
have a call in ten minutes
we need to move through this now whoo
okay let's go let's probably got another
ten but okay all right so let's look at
the next one this is from Marx some Marx
um okay if you look really closely you
can see that there's a wolf hiding in
the negative shape oh right there's some
kind of the thing horror film vibe going
on here from the movie the thing yeah a
little bit a little bit of that vibe
it's got a little texture and some
crunchy edges I don't know I don't know
how I feel about that I feel like you're
bringing a lot of personal POV baggage
on today [ __ ] all that who is my middle
name Chris POV baggage dough
okay I don't know I think it's okay I
think maybe where it hurts a little bit
for me is the K where the K feels a
little like hey we're the star
get out of here K where it feels a
little smaller to make room for that mmm
leg of that are right right doesn't it
feel a little bit smaller
yeah the K feels a little diminished
there does being compacted or like put
tucked behind the are too much like I
think it I like the idea but I think it
was just a little too much there yeah
okay I mean usually I'm a fan of these
negative shape logos you know but I
don't know let's move on next one this
one's a little chilly frosty yeah I
think people are using similar typefaces
right because it also has that vibe I
really like this typeface a lot the R is
open here and I like these really pointy
serifs taper out like that you know
mm-hmm it'd look really good
it's a beautiful typeface stark yeah I
think all of these serif typefaces for
whatever reason seems to work very well
with the letter forms for Stark they do
yeah so this one is similar to the one
that we had reviewed with the wolf's
texture so this one is the ice version
of it mm-hmm I don't know if you have to
thematically make it feel like it's
winter on it I think a beautiful
typeface could work without all the
flourishes that you're adding maybe you
could try a little inline I don't know
right because I think they took some
inspiration from like frozen and some of
the stuff that you showed where they are
infusing a little bit of the story of
the movie yeah to help bring that out
because if they just removed all those
characters then what would it be
I don't know like if they modify this a
like the way they did mmm yeah I do like
that part know where you draw a bar yeah
the the some of the best logos that we
see don't have a giant flourish you know
it's just a little something mm-hmm and
that's all because it kind of if you see
if you see like or hasn't open okay
hasn't open you open this up and it
feels like a family hmm I like that it
doesn't have to be a lot of stuff
so this is a nice one Cody Cody Watkyn
good job let's move on okay this is
Kento Yoshida
he's not gonna leave it just as two
entries it's gotta be at least three or
ten freaking can't tell me Kento Kento
we have some little issues here time
space space that's an OP drawing sorry I
didn't mean to do that shape sorry space
and space there's some issues there and
I am assuming there's a sword here so
the sword
I think it's called iron claw that Jon
Snow is given right now that's just in
the timeline of the story so this is
either a family that knows their logo in
their future before they design their
family logo alright that's where it gets
a little strange for me right because
they're not known for the sword right so
that's the problem okay that's all I
don't know other people have done swords
for Lannister yeah let's move on this
one Matthew and I we stopped on this one
we first I like I'm I like this there's
something weird about it and I like it
and then you're like I don't know but
then we looked it up what was the story
behind this mark I think it was based
off of some Nordic characters alright in
ruins right in ruins yeah yeah yes it
was based off of Nordic runes yeah so
there's something really cool and
ancient about this I like it in the
geometry if you're really cool I think
this is this from Newton and excuse me
Newton has a snowflake logo mhm so he's
looking geometry and reflecting the
elements from his snowflake logo and I
think they tie in really well so I would
just make a really quick comment it does
feel a little modern but I like the way
this r is drawn mm-hmm yeah if we see on
my scene like that's what the Nordic
runes look like but even those those
because I think they were hand done mmm
they feel like they have little bit more
character versus the one that we're
looking at right now maybe feels to
clean and geometric oh yeah I love it
I love it though okay let me do a couple
things what's bugging me is the K and
I'm gonna just draw it red first you see
the space in this space and the line it
doesn't feel right something is off
there so I'm gonna do that let's see if
I can fix this real quick I'm sorry let
me rephrase my statement
see if I can modify this to my own
liking not to imply that it was wrong to
begin with so I kind of like that
Matthew and I also want to change this
okay now I'm gonna add back in again
with a steady hand surgeon that's pretty
good that's what I want to do now you
were saying before
maybe the a was bugging you because it's
closed off right so I'm gonna try a
couple things here I'm gonna try to see
if I can delete this well that's kind of
cool yeah yeah so it's open so just a
little modification and I don't know
maybe it's okay maybe it's not I don't
know you guys let me know I think this
is where the s and the T need a little
love right cuz the arc is super cool and
this needs a little love somehow I don't
know what to do with it so Newton if you
want go ahead and modify it and see what
you come up with let's keep moving
YouTube audience Internet let us know if
you like the little modifications that
we did or if you just like it let me
know it's my load yes very good I like
it
house targaryen our favorite house fire
and blood cuz Danni has dragons
Targaryen the rightful heirs to the
throne the Mad King and all here we go
let's look at it
garyun I like this a lot Matthew so do i
it is sharp yes I like this a lot it
does it feels very appropriate to them
yes feel like they're also a very proud
and Noble family yep
and man I like all the little flourishes
that are coming down the G yeah and and
I like that they're not even it feels
like there's a lot of thought that was
put into where things start and end and
then all the little flourishes like if
you look at the a on the left side and
then the e on the right side they kind
of balance each other because they have
similar swooshes on the crossbars yep so
man this really well done okay so I
think this could exist for this house
targaryen with whatever symbol that you
add and the current symbol is one where
there's like a three-headed dragon with
the tail and stuff so it's gonna look
really good in there somewhere
right there's like three dragons or
somehow they're coming they're coming
right something like that
I can see that working really well now
notice here they didn't try to make this
look like fire right or teeth of a
dragon so it just implies a little
feeling and the feeling I get is
something sharp something's scratching
at this something spiky so watch out and
the letter forms really sit well
together there's enough little
modifications and a little weathering of
the edges well done I'm gonna move on oh
who did that the loot the line of life
Wow
Oh what that's not it I'm sorry who did
it I have two eggs out of this
I cannot read it sorry let me get back
to it there we go it's Bryant Seth
Walker good job Ryan South Walker the
next one up is Osama I boosted Osama up
was it okay now similar little
modifications but when you compare the
two and we cycle back and forth one is
just a little bit more tasteful mm-hmm
and the letter forms are a little bit
more resolved so we toggle back and
forth between osama's versus Bryant
right they're very similar there's
similar ideas right at that but I just
one is just a little tastier yeah that's
it okay so nothing really wrong with
this
I just somebody did it better that's all
the t's a little funky on this one with
Osama has to work on that next one up
whoo Matthew did you add this from
yesterday remember seen as good I think
you did this one's also very nice also
feels like it's Trajan but I'm not sure
yeah this is one I want to call out some
people because they added color to a
black and walk logo this is all what
they did they did so I had to make this
one black and white because I wanted to
test well this one still stand out if it
was completely black and white and not
color so everyone that they didn't pay
attention to the rules shame on you
shame shame shame shame shame
Oh shame shame on you okay I like this
Ashley it's just one little thing and I
like it I just don't like the fact that
there's a white letter in there right
the idea is kind of fun yeah
why can't you just make it in black
don't rely on dainty outlines guys see
it could work yeah nothing to be ashamed
of all right so move on that's all you
need fill it in
Chucky Aryan blood and Fire whoa a lot
of tricks in this one you know what
there's some really cool stuff that's
happening on this letter from too many
cool things for me to talk about you
have a really unique G the Y is really
cool the A's there's some really good
stuff but it's a lot for me to process
so now this I'll just get rid of it
right now we don't need that targaryen
it feels a little bit too delicate for
the house of fire and blood what is it
that you want from me I want something
that feels appropriate Danny I am I'm
sorry mother dragons let's move on okay
I feel like this could be for that house
Martell that we with the Rose the Rose
so high relevant I rel versus house
Tyrell yeah because it feels like a rose
mm-hmm okay let's move on next one
Targaryen okay it's nice I'm gonna go
nothing bad about this one that I can
say I think here a little spacing issue
I wonder if you could do a little bit
more with the bottoms of the T the G and
the Y just to make you feel a bit more
integrated I feel like there's some
spacing issue here let's work on it
mm-hmm that's it good job next up whoo
tar aerion Targaryen guys this is where
I'm have to warn you you put in the
animal then you have the sigil what is
gonna go on everything's gonna fight
everything else just focus on the word
mark that's all you need to do I don't
wanna spend a lot of time talking about
this one I think the dragon looks
pretty cool you know but nice drawing
there I'm just gonna make a little
sharper sharper edges you know so when
I'm drawing I like to have things that
go like that versus like that why is
that it just feels more dynamic the
lines are more interesting to me hmm
if you can cut them did you know is the
difference though so let's let's go a B
on this one before see how it's like
it's kind of a soft belly it doesn't
feel strong right so sharper and edges
that point actually in bit like that it
implies an invisible line that's closing
off the G yep right so you you could see
that the curve of the G a little bit
better the other one so there's some
weight issues too Matt so we would have
to like beef this up a little bit so
that reads okay but don't don't try to
hide the symbol and there's too much
whoa who is this this is Jason Tucker
mothertrucker Wow
beautiful it is it feels ancient I like
this language that we kind of uncovered
and the letter forms integrate together
they feel consistent and it's one kind
of visual language I mean they could
have put a dragon in here and fireballs
but then that would be too much I like
this one Jason mothertrucker
Wow good job yeah and I love how all of
the letters are overlapping it's very
tricky it's like a puzzle if you're
amazed that's what it looks like you
know what it is you you ever play those
games
when you go into the Dungeons & Dragons
store Matthew and they have the metal
puzzles and they're like linked together
mm-hmm and you try to like know that I'm
liking it right that's what when you
said I'm like whoo there it is
boom there it is okay house told us move
on I have to move kind of Lightspeed ash
here
Matthew you may have to take over for me
because mr. mark Contreras and I have to
jump on a call pretty soon okay new
business new business call
okay house Tully family duty and honor
their symbol is a fish I don't know what
kind of fish but they're in the river
lens so Tully there we go boom
I like this mark a lot it is a little
reminiscent of Margo chase so you'll be
doing the late great
Margo chase quite proud if you look at
the work of
we'll chase you'll know what I'm talking
about it really beautifully drawn not
nothing bad for me to say about it I
don't know what has to do with fish
mm-hmm the Riverland but hey who did
this this is Jess Brown just Brown I
think she was the one who did the very
minimal blue sigil where it's just like
the wave and no the the fin coming out
and wonder how these two are gonna
integrate right they feel like they're
in two different universes right maybe
we'll see in the next challenge
Kelly oh now this is pres net present
mech pager pleasure presenting pager
this one feels like take me out to the
ball park hmm a little bit like a like a
like a sports logo from yeah yeah
totally
it's really well drawn I like it these
things are very hard to do I can then
use good person right but it just you
know if anything I would have liked to
have just finished off this way totally
no that's July I don't know anyways I
don't know what I'm talking about let's
move on
house Tyrell Tyrell Tyrell growing
strong this is the one with the flower
finally we get to the flower and here we
go this mark this word Mart is beautiful
to me it's beautiful
we don't need this I don't know why
there's a period in Tyrell this could be
for a mass head for Tyrell magazine you
have the you know the date issue number
and then you you have a little lime and
you have articles underneath it if you
feel you don't talk about Matthew and
that's it for a magazine you like boom
Tyrell for latest and greatest news on
Westeros but feels a little modern it
feels a little too more to model right
yeah but so it's beautiful it's really
nice-looking
so Tom whiting good job on that you you
have a very modern sensibility I do
declare Oh see him Kevin
this is cm Kevin's second entry as far
as I can tell this has got way too much
stuff I'm gonna go fast here this is too
fat right let's see to that
no no typed a shaming but it's too fat
this our it's got too much stuff going
on
wow it's just - whoo it's like hooking
back and oh my goodness okay move on
another one from oh no this is not
another one
this is Joep the viet Joep dove it has
that woodcut look on there
little look kind of Xerox II would cut
mm-hmm just we gotta go all right
Mark's telling me we got to go Matthew
why don't we dance while in swap places
and you take it over from here okay
everything's set up for you and Matthews
gonna take over I leave the kingdom is
yours the hand your the hand here you go
all right well I'm Chris get that Apple
box there we go movie magic right here
all right so I think both of these I
think we're pretty interesting and how
they used the idea of a rose growing
around the why that's pretty nice it's a
little tricky to read from far away I
think as we've already explored
throughout this dream the subtleties are
the things that make it really nice so
if I think for both of you guys if you
were to make that each a little bit more
subtle and not go overboard on that I
think you could have something quite
nice here all right then this is the
last one for a house Tyrell mm-hmm
want to be a Christo right now and say
it's it's reminiscent of the the blind
logo it does read has all the flourishes
maybe that maybe they they looked at
that but this is pretty cool I like the
the the balance of this thing I don't
know if it feels super appropriate for
me that's just my opinion but I really
like the letter forms in here the curls
like if we're looking at let me go here
on Chris's iPad there's some details in
here I want to say right here like this
is a little too plugged up and right
here these curls I don't
feel like our super resolved and I think
if you treated those and opened up the
loops a little bit more so they're a
little bit bigger and those things would
feel much better so exciting Shu ate the
curls right and then there's something
funky happening in this negative space
right here like it feels like it's a
little too plugged up I wish that that
was even all the way through coming
through this this is a pretty nice
crossbar I like this crossbar that's
coming in here on the E that's a nice
way to resolve the space right here can
you do you think you can do that with
other fonts or is it most of like these
the the crossbar yeah the crossbar I
think this is just a nice little
flourish so this person because they
have all these other details like this
coming down right here it feels like
it's related you know these are part of
the same family mm-hmm
so it was just a nice way to anchor this
and I can see that this helps anchor the
the house around here too but even with
a lot of these I don't know that you
have to put the word house in a lot of
the family names or the house names but
this is it's a pretty nice mark overall
that was an Eno colo-colo rhiness color
eNOS sorry
can't pronounce that well yeah so I
think overall if we just adjust these
negative spaces in here and then fix the
loops I think this would be much much
better and then even here like I feel
like on the Tyrrell like you have a lot
of weight on this side of the tee on the
on the letter form where this side feels
like it's a little bit lacking I feel
like if we had something a little bit
heavier on this side we might be able to
balance out the weight of these things
it's tricky Keeton says it feels elegant
but also distracting right cool all
right
well I think actually that is the very
last entry that we are reviewing today
on today's stream so of course we didn't
go through the top 50 just because you
know we didn't have time to go through
everything we tried our best to cover
what we could
and really show off the ones that we
thought were worth talking about so I
think now it's a good time to announce
our top 5 me and Chris already had
discussed yesterday which are the top 5
that we are going to advance that you
guys are gonna all vote on so we could
crown the winner of challenge two of
three of the future Game of Thrones
challenge
so let's this is what we were judging
everything on remember that it's
memorable it's appropriate to the
context to the house and that you did
some level of customization so our top
five drumroll we gotta get this on board
it's alright
so the first of the top five is Newton I
can't read that let's two L's 2l low
rent a low rent a Newton low rent a good
job you are the first of the five this
is for House Stark and it was based off
of those Nordic runes so very very well
done this is our first finalist here
next one we have Lillian Figueroa this
is awesome beautiful beautiful work you
are number two of five next up this is
no surprise to me our buddy
can tell Yoshi Boris Kento Yoshida
coming in hard I think he probably had
three or four entries this round and
this is the one that went through we
looked at this earlier and we decided
that you know if we just made little
modifications to the amount of claws on
the bottom of the the seraphs there that
this could be very very well refined so
congratulations Kento in the next one
Justin mother Tucker for Targaryen House
Targaryen very very beautiful I know we
didn't go in-depth on the review here
cuz Chris was running out of time but I
think both him and I both agree that
this one was very well done nicely
customizing it felt very appropriate for
the house so good job Jason and then the
last person for the top five the future
Game of Thrones challenge is
Bryant's Seth Walker wow this one is
just gorgeous Chris already mentioned
all the beautiful things I talked about
the great details on the arse and the
the G's like this is just fantastic it's
so simple it's not trying to illustrate
anything and I think it just feels so
appropriate for the house so
congratulations to our top five shortly
after the stream I will update the
website so you guys can vote on round 2
and crown your winner from that we will
assign new points for the next round so
this round is the same weight as the
last one so anyone who made top 50 you
guys all get two points each anyone who
made the top five you get four points
each and then whoever will be crowned
the winner of this round 2 challenge is
going to get 6 points and then I will
post up the leaderboard after that so we
can see where everyone is standing
record a lot and we got a lot of new
people on the leaderboard now so I'm
pretty excited so coming up next coming
up next we're going to release a video
probably next week or the week after
depending on Chris's travel schedule and
we are going to announce who won this
round and then we will also announce
challenge number 3 challenge number 3 is
going to be way more difficult and it's
gonna have a lot more points issued for
it so if you even haven't participated
in round 1 or round 2 you could still
make it and possibly be the winner for
round 3 depending on how things shake
out because this is a pretty big
challenge and challenge three is going
to be designing a minimalist poster I
will give you all the details but
there's always going to be super fun I
might even jump in if I have the time
because I really like this challenge and
just for those of you guys who don't
know whoever wins the grand prize of all
three whoever is crowned the winner
you're gonna get the Game of Thrones
bookend seasons 1 through 7 pop Funko
set t-shirts hand of the king pin and we
will bring you on the show so I think
that's pretty much it for us on today's
episode I just want to say thank you
everyone for participating so far in
round 1 & 2
of the future Game of Thrones challenge
thank you everyone who's participated if
you didn't get to the top fifth you
don't be discouraged because all of this
is practice practice makes you better
and the more you practice the better
your skills are and thank you everyone
who's tuned in and paid an attention
here hopefully you guys learn something
let us know if there are any particular
bits of this episode that you
particularly liked call it out with a
timestamp that helps us know what kind
of content you want on our channels and
we're asking you guys to do this more
and more because we want to make more
cut downs we want to make more content
specific to the things that you want so
let us know timestamp it comment and let
us know what you want more of I think
that's it for us Jonah alright I don't
have the the cube music here but that's
alright we will just roll as long as we
can don't forget to comment like and
subscribe hit that Bell so that you get
notified next time please laughs thank
you everyone
and